We're now going to see whether the evolutionary,
evolutionary way of looking at the world gives us any special insight into
mental disorders.
And at the outset I want to acknowledge that there are some special difficulties
in explaining mental disorders.
Yeah.
To offer a null hypothesis.
Then discuss how evolution might enter that kind of picture.
We'll take a look at mental disorders as byproducts of defense systems and as
diseases of homeostasis in Admin and mismatch.
The first point to make is that mental disorders are almost all multi causal.
Most of them,
most of the time have several to many causes.
And that means that any hypothesis for why a mental disorder exists,
uh,
is not going to be mutually exclusive.
We're going to have to entertain several hypotheses at the same time.
Many mental disorders do not have credible equivalence in model systems,
and that means that experimental approaches are out of reach.
We do not really have a credible model system for schizophrenia or autism or
something like that.
So claims in this area of biomedical science need to be treated with particular
skepticism and agnostic patients is especially needed.
Yeah.
Here's an old hypothesis.
Any process that is influenced by several factors,
each of which can vary will be expressed,
is a broad range of phenotypes.
Those are the center of the range will be more frequent and we'll be the ones on
which natural selection acts most strongly.
Those at the extremes will be rare and will not be strongly selected.
Yeah.
Mental disorders represent abnormal cognition and behavior that occur at low
frequency.
Okay.
If they represent the extremes of arrange,
who center is normal,
the normal cognition and behavior are things that are selected and mental
disorders do not need.
Any special evolutionary explanation they are seeing here is the unavoidable
byproducts of tradeoffs that are expressed at the population level,
not within an individual,
but across the distribution of phenotypes found in a population.
Okay.
That picture looks somewhat like this.
We have functional behavior at the center of the distribution of phenotypes and
mental disorders are seen as the rare extremes.
Now,
how might evolution enter that kind of picture?
When evolution produces a novel aspect of cognition or behavior,
it usually does so by modifying some existing process.
This is normally how evolution works.
If we combine that with the previous figure,
then we expect mental disorders to be associated with underlying functions that
evolved for other reasons and are normally expressed close to the center of that
trait distribution.
There are correlations with other traits,
could be arbitrary reflections of some historical process.
They could also belong to several disease categories including monogenic
disorders and catastrophic environmental insults as well as the ones we
discussed.
Next is vulnerabilities of defense systems,
so how might mental disorders be?
Vulnerabilities of defense systems,
anxieties,
phobias,
and some forms of obsessive compulsive disorders are exaggerated behavioral
defenses,
anxieties and phobias or excessive expressions of behavioral defenses that
normally avoid dangerous environments.
Germaphobia and excessive hygiene are a form of obsessive compulsive disorder
that exaggerates behavioral avoidance of pathogens.
Hoarding behavior may now represent inappropriate and excessive expression of
what was once normal foraging behavior.
How might mental disorders be?
Diseases of homeostasis and mismatch?
Well,
such diseases,
diseases of homeostasis and mismatch recur in systems that are designed to be
adjustable with set points that define the states that the system's designed to
maintain.
Such systems are vulnerable to dysregulation because disrupting the set points
produces extremes of expression.
Behavioral homeostatic systems use internal mechanisms of reward and punishment
who set points can be disrupted by exposure to novel substances.
One example may be drug addiction,
which is going to be discussed next.
So to summarize,
mental disorders or Har,
hard to explain because they have multiple causation and because credible model
organisms are not available for experiments,
a simple no hypothesis is that some mental disorders represent the rare tales of
distributions of cognition and behavior.
Who centers are normal and selected.
Mental disorders can also result from mirror rare monogenic mutations.
They can be byproducts of defense systems and they can be diseases of
homeostasis and mismatch.